[Music]
so hello everyone
do you hear me well yeah cool hola
um so i'm going to talk to you about the
development of the datus package that's
part of the r for data science
translation so this talk is about how
is to be an r user when english is not
your first language
so we have to acknowledge that there's a
language gap
that people that doesn't speak english
or doesn't are
that are not very proficient in english
that can be a very difficult thing to do
so for example when you try to learn
something new you i don't know you want
to insert some data into a vector and
want to learn how to use the event
function
you may run into this resource there are
our cookbook
so you want to learn how to use this uh
function and you have this whole context
that explains you how to use it
but when english is not your first
language and and you're not very
proficient that context doesn't exist at
all
so you have to try to figure out how to
understand that function
without the context and sometimes that
can be very difficult
so someone may ask why don't you just
learn english
that will be much easier okay
well that's a possibility but for many
people learning english is a privilege
the country where i came from i live in
chile um
one level of an english course can cost
you like 500
but the minimum wage is 350. so
it's not only costly but we also have to
think it's time consuming
so you want to learn art so why i have
to learn english
first and then lennar that's not the
idea
so happier users like me want that
everybody learns are
so sometimes we have dreams like this
one for example have our for data
science translated to spanish and have
reba so o'reilly you can help us
so the story i'm going to tell you
starts in 2017 and as many
stories in the r community it started on
twitter
so hardly we can announce that um for
data science was going to be translated
into chinese french korean portuguese
russian serbian
cool so marcel alfaro from the costa
rican our community asked
well what about spanish and had it said
strangely
no and that's very strange because
spanish is the language that had the
second most amount of uh
native users so there's a lot of
spanish-speaking
art users that want to read this
so on in 2018 edgar ruiz from
our studio he forked the original
repository and decided to start the
translation
but he didn't do nothing at all because
this is very difficult to do
translated a book so he needed a
community and he was alone in this
anna a couple of months later at our
open sion conf
laurasion hardly what about the
translation and he said no it's not
going to happen orel is not interested
in spanish
but you can do it if you want so she
spread the news around the
our ladies network and on twitter and
the next week we have the first
conference call between all the people
that were interested in this
project and just two days after the
video conference we have our x sticker
because you know if you don't have a
next sticker
you're not a real r
project so we became a sticker-driven
project we have a team and sticker so
we can start so everyone start forking
the repository
and 21 people were involved with the
translation
from different backgrounds uh from
different countries
and we have another around 30 people
that review those translations so this
was about
50 people effort project so all these
people
um speaks different varieties of spanish
which is very useful
because you don't want to be rude you
know translated something in some way
and that's
very offensive in another part of latin
america
people from different backgrounds there
were people that were from statistics
from biology from social science from
the humanities
also people with different are
experienced experts and novices
and people with different github
experience and this was very risky
because you have we fork the repository
and the people fork
our fork so you have around 30 people
trying to manage
how to contribute so in this first
conference we decide two things first
that we want to translate the text
and the data sets that are used in the
in the book
because they're not they're useful not
only for the book but for teaching art
and also which infrastructure we were
going to use
so we use mainly github and slack in
github we have our fork of the book
we have a repository with all the
documentation of the project
and the repository for the package
and we have responsibilities edgar
was leading the development of the
package
but i was involved with the taking care
that we didn't break the
the repository and i was involved with
the translation
and coordinating the whole process so
github is very useful for translation
because you can have like
both versions of the task and reviewers
can
put comments in between so they can make
suggestions how to improve the
translation
and slack was also very useful while we
can organizes
but also because of polls because there
we have to make
made many decisions about how we are
going to translate some stuff
for example we have empty cars
we have two translated cars and we can
state cars in three different ways in
spanish
so we have to decide altos coches or
carlos
so autos one and now we have emmett
and there's some other very difficult
stuff to decide for example we have the
pipe
and in spanish all nouns has a
grammatical gender so we have to decide
if the pipe was going to be
masculine or feminine so we made a poll
and everyone voted that
a pipe was masculine except me because
for me the pipe was a she
so now i have to like change all my mind
about how i thought about the pipe
so we decided uh that we want to
translate the text and the data sets and
for the text there was there were
previous experiences that were very
helpful and for example the
the carpentries have has translated some
lessons to spanish
and they have this um guide with the
agreements about how
they are translating technical um words
so we get inspired about that and also
the programming historian it's a project
a website
where we publish a peer review tutorials
that help people from the humanities
to learn digital tools and has a version
in spanish and french
so there are like guidelines for
reviewers for translation for authors
and that's very
was very useful to get inspired by that
and what about the data set there were
two possible approaches
what we wanted is for example we have
the diamonds data set
we went diamantes and we wanted to have
like the variable translated
and the name of the the different values
and one possible approach was just to
for example rename
the variables and then change the
translate the name of the
values but another approach was using
datalang
a package that edgar ruiz developed that
has this function that's called
translated data
that takes a young file with the
translation
the specification for the translation
and as a result you get your dataset
translated
so how it works you have this yum file
so
you put which is the search packet
the original data set in english how
it's going to be named in spanish
you specify how you want to translate
the variables
for example price became pressure and
the description
and you also explain which values you
want to translate it
and you also translated the help so you
have
a documentation in spanish also
so you not only get the data set
translated
but also you get the help page for the
data set
so that's very useful for people who are
learning
so this approach of translating the book
and the data set using this packet make
very easy to contribute because you can
participate in a packet just
by knowing how to edit a yam file
so last year when we were developing the
package
we set a proposal to toulouse but we
the package wasn't finished so we came a
conference driven package
we have to finish it before the
conference um
so we were working fine but when we
decided to send the package to crown we
realized it was too bulky
because we have like a package with a
lot of datasets inside
so what we decided to do was that the
dataset translate on the fly
so actually the translated dataset are
not in the package
in the package you only find the yam
files
so we have these two functions that
translated the data on the fly once you
call for example diamantes
it goes to find the young translated
dataset and offer you the translated
version
so that makes the package much lighter
so we were very happy with that but one
day we were trying to do something and
we realized we were not able to call the
the data set that way and we were like
very stuck and hardly
remember that this function exists
delayed assigned
and that helped us to solve that so now
you can call the
datas a packet whichever one a way you
want
so we are um in kran now
um um edgar was involved in was leading
the development of the package
and pachama originally and i helped with
the whole process and also people from
the community
got involved and where we are now
uh the dataset are all translated the
code we had to
edit all the code from the book because
it has like the original data
sets the translations are ready and the
reviews are ready so we have like
the first complete version of the book
in es dot
r4ds handy dot ns so
now we have this first version that
people can use to learn
and are and there was um
a thing we have to decide what about the
edition because we want this
book to be updated every time so i
decided that
a good idea is to watch the repository
so every time they change something in
the written repository i can
edit it back to the book and one day
january 15 i woke up and i really we can
collapse my inbox
with with 42 messages because they
decided that that was the day to update
all the pull requests that were in the
in the original repository so i thought
i was able to be
a conference driven editor but i failed
so
i'm still like um making the last
changes
so is this really the end of the project
now that the book is ready
um this started in 2018 but i think it's
a project that will last forever
because what we have created is not just
a translation and a book package what we
created was human and technical
infrastructure
to shorten the language gap that
currently exists
and i think our big contribution
developing the datas package
was creating brand new errors because
people now if they
fail using the package they are not
going to find
like um ways to solve it
alone but i think this is a opportunity
because in each failing is a way to make
our communities stronger
so thank you very much
so once again so once again if you'd
like to ask a question
we use the app app.sli.do
we one question here have you seen an
increase in spanish speaking our users
since the release of the package uh yes
i think
um so we put the book online
uh from the beginning so you can start
like
using the chapters some of them were
translated very
fast so yeah there are many people that
are using the package to teach
so it has that now alive outside the
book translation
fabulous that's the only question we
have
well please thank you